The Joe Rogan Experience there's gonna
be conspiracy theories about why Mike
Tyson lit that dude up on that plane
real simple that dude was a douchebag
and he was like you see the other videos
Annoying one of the baddest
[ __ ] that's ever walked the
face of the Earth talk about kicking a
beehive what the [ __ ] are you doing dude
um that's not even kicking a beehive
it's like smashing it's headbutting a
beehive it's like trying to put your
dick in a sleeping Bear's mouth like he
just walked up and was like I'm gonna
lower my wiener right into the bear's
mouth Mike Tyson also there's a video
that came out of the angle of him
talking to someone and he's like talking
[ __ ] in a way where you're like this
guy's hammered and doesn't know what's
coming
because I bet in his head he's like he
won't punch me he can't punch me
oh my God I bet he's a guy that thinks
Mike Tyson's hands are registered Lethal
Weapon
he strikes me as that guy he was like
any by the way I saw the guy's shape and
I was like that guy would kick the [ __ ]
out of me well it's so much better than
the things that make you confident yeah
things that make you confident are
dangerous like that's what it means like
or booze and you get Mike Tyson punching
on you on a Jet Blue flight yeah yeah
that guy's probably on a bunch of [ __ ]
the guy who uh Mike Tyson punched
apparently according to the New York
Post uh has a lengthy criminal history
uh uh well in that case if he's if he's
had a lot of [ __ ] ups and he's a you
know a bad person or whatever he's gonna
go to jail at least he got to get his
ass kicked by a famous person if you
find yourself or Mike Tyson's reaching
over the back of an airline seat and
punching you in the face I think you
probably earned it I think he probably
earned it yeah I I don't think he
thought you climb into uh I don't think
it was for kicking his chair right I
don't think he was he's a [ __ ] guy
was super annoying man yeah and he was
like over the thing you just can't yeah
it's like people get crazy they think
that just because he's uh you know he's
Mike Tyson he's famous he can't just
punch you
you're annoying him he's gonna just
[ __ ] hit you like a normal person
would you know hecklers do that though
yeah some you know that like they'll be
talking and you're like hey shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah they didn't bring you down here
they didn't put you up at the [ __ ]
Extended Stay they're not amplifying you
and stop stop talking that's why booze
when people are like when I have friends
like I'm calling your show dude we're
going to the bar first no no don't who
wants to get drunk and sit silently in a
dark room no one you want to get drunk
and go pay attention not only that like
if there's a guy who thinks he might be
funny that's the time they all think
they're funny yeah they wanna know what
to say I got you uh and then you know
the classic after the show helped and
you're like man I yelled yeah I wonder
if that guy was like I helped that
flight